students and staff from roseman
university are stepping up to help
administer the covid19 vaccine
thank you so much for staying with us
here at 6 30. i'm sasha loftis
8 news now reporter katie houston shows
us how they're holding
vaccination pods to reach even more
community members
on saturday morning 300 front line
health care workers and elderly
community members
received their first dose of the moderna
vaccine
it felt no different than my recent
shingles and pneumonia shock that i got
last year
felt no different than that roseman
university of health sciences is hoping
to vaccinate more than one thousand
people per week
in order to accomplish this they brought
in faculty and staff
as well as student volunteers from the
nursing and pharmacy programs
i just wanted to help so i think that
part of being a nursing student you
really just want to help the community
so
when they gave us the opportunity i took
it not only is this great experience for
the students
but it also adds to the manpower needed
to vaccinate the entire community
it's an all hands on deck effort this is
the largest
vaccination effort that in modern times
we need as many people as possible that
are trained to do so
vaccinating and getting shots in arms
the clinic was appointment based with
individuals showing up to get the
vaccine then waiting in the lobby for a
post-vaccination
observation period i knew that at 95
efficacy i felt very comfortable getting
this today it was very quick and
painless
and everyone was super nice at the
clinic wanting for
myself family to get back to some
normalcy and
also for the country we get vaccines for
everything else as an
older person i get vaccines for shingles
and pneumonia
so why not for covid roseman university
will hold another appointment based
vaccination clinic next week in
henderson
kate houston 8 news now 8 news now has
you covered when it comes to getting
notified to get the vaccine
to get notified you need to fill out a
form we have a link to it on our website
it will ask you if you are an employer
or an individual
and ask for contact information once
it's your time to be vaccinated you will
be notified
there are also forms specifically for
the elderly those again are all on our
website 8newsnow.com